c'est une première dans les yvelines à
versailles une auto école sociale a vu
le jour en décembre dernier un
dispositif d'insertion partenariale
porté par le conseil départemental est
soutenu par une aide de 200 mille euros
du fonds social européen
cette auto école sociale comme son nom
l'indiqué tire son importance du fait
que l'accès à l'emploi est totalement
empêché par l'absence de permis
surtout quand on est en grande couronne
de la région parisienne parce que
l'offre de transport en commun est
insuffisante le permis souvent
indispensable pour accéder à l'emploi en
zone rurale un précieux sésame qui
revient généralement trop cher dans une
auto école classique ce qu'elle est
différent par rapport à un auto écoles
classiques c'est déjà les moyens
d'intégrer cette auto école puisque en
fait personne ne vient s'inscrire en
direct ça passe toujours par des
référents sociaux actuellement accueille
surtout des bénéficiaires rsa des
personnes ayant la prime d'activité sous
réserve d'un certain financement mais
aussi des demandeurs d'emploi dans le
cadre de l'accompagnement global
ici les modalités d'enseignement sont
différentes
la formation est adaptée au profil de
chacun dans des classes de 10 à 15
personnes pour une moyenne de dix heures
de cours de code par semaine dans une
haute école classique on corrige pas
qu'elle ne dise pas nos erreurs s'est on
voit là encore y jouer en à faumont sais
pas pourquoi alors qu'ici nous explique
pour quelles raisons la faux quoi j'ai
eu beaucoup moins de mal à pouvoir avoir
le cot la première phase les loupés et
après j'ai retravaillé pendant trois
semaines à fond avec le moniteur et
c'est vrai que chez les hauts de seine
une participation de 250 euros minimum
est demandé à chaque participant
sur les 20 premiers adhérents quatre
personnes ont déjà obtenu leur permis
un résultat qui semble être une réussite
puisque en septembre une seconde auto
école sociale verra le jour à mantes la
jolie